[Music]  [Music]  I'm gonna ask MJ to marry me  the man has to put his wife before  himself  can you do that yeah I think I can we  have some new information this is your  uncle's actual killer we lost his trail  two days ago  this they killed my uncle and he's still  out there  everybody needs help sometimes Peter  even Spiderman ribbon just like a poison  that can take us over before you know it  can turn you into something ugly soon a  suit where'd this come from the power  feels good to lose yourself to it  whoa Spidey love the new outfit remember  Ben Parker what does it matter to you  anyway everything  why would I want to push you away I love  you  kill your father  [Music]  we've all done terrible things to each  other oh we have to forgive each other  or everything we ever world I mean  nothing I need your help I have to stop  it  [Music]  this could be the end of spider-man  [Applause]  [Music]